I've never covered a child sex case like
it the abuser a young middle-class
British man this is horrific his victims
scores of vulnerable young children in
Southeast Asia they didn't think there
was anything that was going on so they
just didn't suspect anything
I'm on the trail of one of Britain's
most prolific pedophiles Richard Huckle
he still only 30 years old
happy times and perhaps the last
together for the Huckle family soon
after this photograph was taken
Richard Huckle returned to Southeast
Asia back to his extraordinary secret
life of child sex-abuse
on another visit home he was arrested
and the vast scale of his crimes began
to emerge Huckle had used his religion
and a fast-track teaching qualification
to Joop his way into a poor community he
then spent nine years raping their
babies toddlers older children much of
it he filmed and shared with other
pedophiles
huckle was a bright child winning a
place at the prestigious Harvey Grammar
School in Folkston but he achieved only
modest GCSE exam results at 16 he joined
fellow pupils doing project work in
Namibia southern Africa he later
returned to school did poorly in exams
and left to study photography at college
school friend Scott Chapman remembered
huckle as a loner he never seemed off or
anything like that is just seemed like
like a normal person as if just a very
very quiet and didn't really talk about
that home and things like that
huckle began posting hundreds of
pictures on the internet mostly of
children none of these is a victim
a fellow poster was suspicious and wrote
this of him after reading your posts I
think you're weird you like Asians
especially children seem to have an
obsession about them looking for
churches wanting to come to Asia and so
forth how does one tell a normal person
from a weirdo maybe their writings give
them away Huckle responded okay I admit
that I'm not the most normal of people
but I think the comments you're making
are a little extreme I didn't
particularly have a decent social life
in my teenage hood mainly as my school
and my friends live 20 miles away and
going to an all-boys school didn't help
matters either he was baptized at a
local church and attended various UK
churches of a particular ethnic
religious community for legal reasons we
can't identify that community huckle
helped at the sunday-school and wrote on
his blog kids have really taken to me as
their giant playmate and later it feels
like I have a split personality or alter
ego where at times on this quiet
reserved Englishman but with the
community I act like a young boy and
seem more comfortable around kids
huckle worked at a local supermarket and
then at a mobile-phone factory while he
agonized over choosing a career he wrote
I'm as stressed as hell I have no idea
what I'm going to do with the next few
years of my life I just hope God guides
me along the right route Richard Huckle
spent a gap year in the Malaysian
capital Kuala lumper he worked in an
orphanage
he was also placed as a Sunday school
teacher at a community church we can't
name it he wrote on his blog after my
second week of teaching there I became
passionately fond of community culture
and became very involved with the church
and its members he was welcomed
immediately someone like like you said
Richard Huckle who is an Englishman he's
intelligent he's coming to do us a
favour is what the community may be
thinking who are we that someone like
him should come to us therefore we have
to go out of a way to make him
comfortable and when children start
saying things if if indeed they did we
don't even know if they raise an alarm
but if they did then you know very
likely they would not have been believed
over him Richard Huckle used a Malaysian
website to promote himself as a private
tutor he made much of the teaching
certificate he got after a two month
course with the British Council
I followed his trail to the offices of
the council which promotes British
business and education abroad here he
took and passed a short Selter course a
certificate in English language teaching
to adults he appeared in a promotional
video his teaching certificate helped
give him access to his target community
and its children when I telephoned the
council its press spokesman said no one
would be interviewed when I called at
its offices where Huckle took the course
I had trouble even getting past security
there was still no interview but the
council said in a statement we have
reviewed our involvement of Richard
Huckle with the British Council and
apart from his participation in the
Selter course we have no records to
indicate that he was ever engaged as a
teacher in Malaysia with us either for
adult students or children we have no
plans to review our interaction with
graduates of our English teaching
courses we have a clearly defined
process for people who enroll in our
Selter courses responsibility for any
pre-employment screening as well as
monitoring their performance at work are
the responsibility of the eventual
employer Malaysia is a diverse society a
rich ethnic mix of Malays Chinese
Indians Filipinos and Indonesians
we're not allowed to report which
community Huckle targeted the country
has a variety of religions predominantly
Muslim but also Buddhism Hindu and
traditional Chinese faiths chuckles
victims were Christian to protect the
identity of the many victims there are
heavy reporting restrictions on this
case we can reveal very little detail of
the small community where Richard Huckle
committed his many crimes we're driving
about half an hour to a suburb of Kuala
lumper
this is the church Huckle belonged to
for six years he taught at the Sunday
School attended services and took many
photographs of children
a priest played down huckle's
connections with the congregation we'd
be very keen to talk to you about
Richard couple of Google trouble about
his time here husband the little dude we
think he was here for some years
he wasn't militia was I'm doing we're
all happy here
you knew him virtual doctor and you know
the crimes he's committed a nobody
yuck
you know he was you know he was accused
of child sex crimes and how is the
community recovering is it you don't
want a discrete number one huh
he was not a regular here he comes off
and on and the so-called cars are not at
law committed this commuted all he ran a
Sunday school here hope was the
Discworld or someone yeah and they were
not thing to do here and the community
was opposed the record or nothing not at
all here which one was it then not good
or which community usually the mughals
no okay thank you
huckle used his church contacts to
arrange private English tuition for
children living in the poorer parts of
the city in one of these homes Huckle
taught for brothers and sisters it's an
area of Kuala lumper that most tourists
never see British investigators describe
the community Huckle targeted as
extremely close-knit trustworthy naive
and poorly educated when they were told
what had happened
community leaders refused to believe
that Huckle had abused their children
there were warning signs but Huckle
survived any suspicions one day he wrote
on his blog was accused of abducting the
girl after taking her alone when she
ended up wetting herself generally I
think in Malaysia we don't think and
believe that things like this do happen
why not perhaps it is a belief that this
is a more Western a rich nation problem
we don't think that it could happen in
our own backyard but it did happen for
nine years Richard Huckle had been
committing monstrous crimes against many
of the children in trust
did to his care as a cover he posted
many innocent photographs of his victims
on the legitimate internet but on the
encrypted websites of the dark web
he also filmed and photographed himself
abusing them and shared the images with
other pedophiles in a post he wrote
about one victim I'd hit the jackpot
a three-year-old girl as loyal to me as
my dog and nobody seemed to care
he was caught when Australian police
stumbled across his online activities
during an investigation into other
suspects huckle was arrested at Gatwick
Airport when he flew home for Christmas
2014
he was eventually charged with 91
serious sex assaults on 23 children they
were victims in an extraordinary case
that threatened to overwhelm
investigators and the British courts
police believe he attacked up to 200
children one of the last photographs of
Richard Huckle before he left Malaysia a
half-smile perhaps he suspected his dark
secret was soon to be exposed on arrival
in the UK Huckle was arrested questioned
and bailed he went home to his family in
Kent the house where he'd grown up on
Christmas Day his parents threw him out
on Facebook huckle messaged his best
friend I feel bad enough dragging you
into this as anyone known to be
associated with me now will be tainted
I'll call my solicitor on Monday so I
can get a clearer picture of what the
future could hold but life as I know it
is over this arrest has broken so many
hearts
at the National Crime Agency
investigators discovered 20,000 indecent
photographs and videos he'd taken of his
young victims and they discovered his
encrypted commentary on images he shared
with fellow pedophiles
huckle wrote of one victim I was going
to lure him into the bedroom and have
sex with him but I think he noticed the
trap and fled I'll get him next time he
posted pictures of himself abusing a
victim on a crowdfunding website a bid
to raise money to fund his travel and
abuse huckle was reared charged and kept
in prison to await trial he denied
everything in prison he sent his best
friend a voice message this is Richard
um just lately not so remanded in prison
but I've been transferred to HMP
Belmarsh now my prison numbers just to
wish you Merry Christmas and you still
want to keep in touch then just send me
a letter sometime the Old Bailey
prosecutors planned three separate
trials they doubted that one jury alone
could cope with viewing so much
harrowing evidence lawyers discussed
having counselors on standby in the end
Huckle accepted he would go to jail
and pleaded guilty to 71 out of the 91
charges the list of charges to which
Huckle eventually pleaded guilty ran to
five pages it was oddly color-coded the
document was heavily redacted like no
other before it it had locations and the
dates of his crimes his victims names
were removed replaced with letters but
there was no disguising the severity of
what Richard Huckle did some victims he
abused over several years the youngest
was six months old the eldest 12 there
were girls and boys some crimes were
multiplied many times more than half
carried a maximum life sentence he'd
even written a guide to help fellow
pedophiles avoid exposure all the crimes
Huckle confessed to were committed in
Malaysia though he had travelled widely
and worked with vulnerable children
elsewhere
unlike other parts of Southeast Asia
Malaysia is not notorious as a
pedophiles playground it doesn't have an
infamous red-light district they scratch
the surface and you'll readily find sex
for sale
huckle arrived in 2006 and lived here on
and off until 2014 his crimes cover all
those years
UK investigators established that huckle
had taken some of his victims to the
coast at Port Dickson he photographed
many children here an hour's drive from
Kuala lumper it's the nearest leisure
Beach to the city one of the
extraordinary aspects of this case is
that investigators interviewed none of
the victims they thought it would be too
much of an extra trauma for them
the investigators relied instead on
huckel's admission of what he'd done and
the videos and photographs he took of
himself abusing the children
and that's the number for the orphanage
yes at least one of huckle's victims had
been living in an orphanage again we
can't identify it but I drove out there
I traveled with a local colleague hello
I think I this is Martin when we arrived
a group of children were reading Enid
Blyton books we spoke briefly to the
orphanage owner he told us Huckle turned
up one day and removed a child from the
home we just wanted to know this was
where Richard Huckle worked
no you never work here and these things
also not was here funny I told earlier
the children actually happened
everything before he came here
after the camera he came twice to the
kitchen room the doctor Ferran wanted a
yeah so he took two children from here
one one child and what happened to that
child idly what was their purpose not in
this place and all was him to shower the
children now are they not in both
miserable Ely was earlier before the
skin serum after they returned by the
Malaysian government which a woman that
you met Richard Huckle yes I love him
too I speaking to children
I'm open with other under the mother
console and what was he like he's like
oh yeah you know what he said what'd the
police say he did what do you think of
that he's a very bad man
sometimes Huckle took children to the
Kuala Lumpur city centre Park it's a
place for the energetic and for the more
laid-back the perfect spot for a selfie
of the Petronas Twin Towers
the dancing fountains are a major
tourist attraction
especially for children how call took
innocent pictures of the youngsters he
brought here these are photographs of
one of his victims a girl of perhaps
seven or eight she's smiling for his
camera Huckle wrote about her spent most
of the week looking after her as nobody
else will
on the chargesheet this victim is child
be Huckle admitted raping her when she
was 10 and 11 years old and carrying out
other serious sex assaults on her from
the age of six but police believe he did
much more to her Huckle shared abuse
pictures of her on the dark web and
wrote it's quite amazing to have stuck
with the same child lover for so many
years and I hope from the images you
have seen enjoyed watching her grow it's
not often in child porn you can compare
the bodies of a five year old and a 12
year old that are the same girl I'm sure
I'll have plenty more sex with her in
the future after huckel's confession
british investigators engaged a child
protection charity to help it approach
the community to explain what had
happened to its children but the charity
workers said they weren't told any of
the details of huckel's crimes I showed
them you've got a very extensive list
here very very very very detailed this
is what is it
we were actually approached by the
British police back in December 2014 and
they didn't give us much information so
we went in there really with with
nothing so we went in there and
approached the communities as an NGO you
know doing prevention and sexual abuse
work child sexual abuse work and working
with communities given them safety
workshops and talks to parents and to
the community leaders but without
telling them something is that
absolutely no information was given to
them at all a government minister in
charge of child protection said that she
too knew nothing of huckel's crimes as
at this moment we don't know anything
about these kids as you said the
persecution is happening in England and
the victims are unknown
and so we would of course like to help
that is paranoid that is our duty
as I've said where the victims here
especially if they're Malaysians
definitely we will help a counseling for
a start of course but at the moment we
don't know who they are it's horrible if
it is true it is horrible it's not
something to be tolerated
of course and we will do anything to
protect our children and to help them if
we know about them
the UK's National Crime Agency insisted
it did alert the Malaysian authorities
as soon as it had identified huckle and
before it arrested him in 2014 the
agency also said it had removed images
of huckel's victims from five social
media sites and was working tirelessly
to take down all others we painstakingly
analyzed my new detail of what he was
saying and the photographs he was taken
and as a result of that we found that
the location of the abuse was happening
in Malaysia
Richard Huckle groomed those children
and he groomed them to a point that he
was certain that no matter what he did
to them they would not tell their
parents of the abuse that they were
suffering from him in huckel's hometown
news of his crimes have shocked his
friends and acquaintances they're trying
to understand the enormity at what he
did a lot of children
we talking a baby here six months old
it scares me the fact that someone can
change so quickly genuinely generally
shocked yes it does it makes you feel
sick a couple of the other guys that
will be friends with have kids in this
age range I mean they're a little bit
older than mine but the fact that six
four five he may have even been around
our friends kids at this age but what
have Richard huckel's family
how have they reacted it appears his
parents old up and moved away as soon as
they could his elder brother did not
want to discuss him how cool
sister-in-law told me none of his family
will speak about him none of us ever
want to see Richard again Richard Huckle
wasn't an opportunist sex attacker he
was a predator who targeted and groomed
his victims and abused them
systematically over many years the judge
said his crimes were of the utmost
gravity and he warned him to expect to
go to prison for life